JONATHAN SHNEIER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for those of you who read
all the way through the title
and still came.
My name is Jonathan.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google Doodle team,
and we're here to
talk about how we
built our first big multiplayer
game, the 2018 Halloween
Doodle.
And there we go.
OK.
So we've divided our
story into three parts.
I'm going to give you some
background and talk about how
we approach the
design process, then
Joseph is going to talk about
designing the Open Match
matchmaker.
And then Brian is
going to talk about how
we scaled up and launched
our production backends.
So Doodles, who are we and
what are we talking about?
Our job is basically to use
technology to make Google fun,
to surprise and
delight our users.
When we talk about
Doodles, we mean this--
the illustrations,
animations, and games that
replace the Google logo to
celebrate notable people,
events, and holidays.
Here are a few examples
of ways we've explored
web technology in the past.
Our first game was
"PAC-MAN" in 2010.
It's still one of
our most popular.
Nothing like peaking early.
In 2012, we built
the synthesizer
to celebrate Robert Moog using
the then new Web Audio API.
People can make four
track recordings
and share them
with their friends.
In 2016, we decided to
try mobile development.
To celebrate the Olympics,
we built a series
of sports mini games into the
Google App on Android and iOS.
So that brings us to
Halloween 2018, which
is the subject of this talk.
For this Doodle we
decided to tackle
a new challenge, multiplayer.
The whole world searches
on Google every day.
What if we could give all
these people a fun way
to interact with each other?
So right off the bat, we had
a few problems to deal with.
First off, we're not
multiplayer game developers.
All of our previous games ran
entirely in the user's browser.
We don't know how to build and
run a fleet of game servers,
and we don't have any
experience with cloud platforms.
That's unfortunate because
we have a lot of users,
and we're going to
need a lot of servers.
Also, most of our
users aren't gamers
or, at least, they
didn't come to play.
They came to search.
And finally, we're
a very small team.
How are we possibly going to
pull off such a big project?
Well, we did anyway.
We ran for two days
in 62 countries,
and we got 100 million players.
So how did we get there?
First thing we had to learn was
how to do multiplayer at all.
So we had a hackathon to see
what we could do in a week.
We ended up with this tank
combat capture the flag game.
We had a play test at
the end of the week,
and we knew we had something
when people started shouting
at each other across the room.
So now we had some idea
of how to do multiplayer,
and we needed to focus on
the second problem, which is
how to design for our audience.
Our target demographic
is everyone
who uses the internet,
which is pretty broad.
And we generally go
for cute art styles,
and try to find simple mechanics
that are fun for everyone.
And the way we do that
is through a process
of rapid prototyping
and frequent play tests.
Here's a couple
of the prototypes
that didn't make the cut.
So what does that mean for
our multiplayer Doodle?
Because our users
didn't necessarily
come seeking a game, we
wanted to get them in and out
as quickly as possible.
We also wanted to avoid direct
user-to-user interactions
for a couple of reasons.
First, PvP is not
really on-brand for us.
Remember, this whole
game is basically
a glorified corporate logo.
So second, we wanted
a mechanic that
wouldn't be
frustrating for people
on slow, unreliable, or
high latency networks.
Finally, we wanted to keep the
backends as simple as possible,
both because of
the massive scale
and because this was our
first time trying this.
The project was
ambitious enough already.
So these considerations
led us to make
some technical decisions, which
shaped the design of the game.
We'd have short,
but exciting matches
with relatively few players,
but massive numbers of them
using highly parallelizable
game server instances.
We'd keep matchmaking
complexity to a minimum.
We just wanted players to
play on the closest servers
to keep latency down, and we
could rely on the Cloud Load
Balancer to handle that for us.
We didn't need fancy skill-based
matchmaking or stat-keeping,
since it's a super casual game,
and it's only live for two days
anyway.
Game server instances
could be short-lived.
Since there's no player
progression or stateful world,
we could create
and destroy servers
as needed to meet player demand.
Our first prototype
architecture was as simple
as we could possibly make it.
We used Node.js
for our game server
so that we could write
everything in JavaScript,
and share code between
client and server.
Communications were
handled by Websockets,
and we kept the client
as simple as possible.
It sent player
input to the server
and rendered server
updates as they arrived.
All the game logic
happened on the server.
At this point, we had
a working prototype,
but it started to
become apparent
that our system didn't scale
well past about one developer.
We were running game servers
by SSHing into a Cloud VM
and running Node on
the command line.
Each developer manually
managed their own single VM,
and we had no automation, or
configuration, or maintenance,
and no easy way to scale
up to more servers.
So we needed to figure
out how to do it for real.
We started researching
the Google Cloud Platform.
Mark Mandel, who you'll
hear from if you come back
for the next talk,
introduced us to Kubernetes
via his blog series, "Scaling
Dedicated Game Servers
with Kubernetes."
Kubernetes would solve
several problems.
It would give us an easy way
to configure, and manage,
and scale our game
servers, and it would also
help with the
development process.
Once we had containerized
the game servers,
we could easily run in the
same containers locally
and in the cloud, which brought
our development environment
much closer to production.
This allowed us to separate
backend infrastructure
development from development
of the game itself.
So here's what things
looked like once
we had converted to Kubernetes.
Game clients connect
to a matchmaker.
This is not yet Open Match.
It's just a very
basic Node server
that keeps a queue
of clients in memory.
When enough clients are
queued to form a match,
the matchmaker uses
the Kubernetes API
to launch a new game server.
The clients then connect
directly to the game server
and they play.
When the match is over, the
game server shuts itself down.
So this architecture was good
enough to let us scale up
and begin load testing.
This allowed us to begin to
estimate the resources we'd
need for a full
scale production,
and to answer a very
important question--
can we actually afford
to do this launch at all?
It also let us begin doing some
debugging of client and server
behavior at scale, making
sure the system behaved
well in the face of client
disconnects and reconnects,
clients who went
through matchmaking,
but never connected to
the game servers, clients
on bad networks-- all
the fun stuff that
happens in the real world.
So things were
starting to look good,
but we still had a
lot of questions.
And we knew our homespun
matchmaker couldn't scale,
so we called in
the professionals.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Thank you, sir.
Hello.
I'm Joseph, and I work
for Google Cloud Platform.
The other two gentlemen
you'll hear from today
both worked on the Doodle.
So Google is working
with the games industry.
We're focused on helping
developers succeed,
and Cloud is really at the
center of those efforts.
We want to help you
create great games,
connect with players globally,
and scale your business.
So we're working with all
the other Google teams
to try and bring
that vision to life.
So in 2016, the
Doodle team first
approached us with
this idea of, we
want to make a multiplayer game.
So we had a couple of
meetings over the first year
when they were still
kicking around the idea.
And we identified
the same challenges
that Jonathan already
mentioned, which is they
had pretty limited experience
with multiplayer backends.
But also, we
recognized there was
a big strength, in that their
team was small and unified.
The backend and the client
teams could very easily
go over to each
other's desk and help
make game design decisions that
could make the backend actually
simple enough to scale
for 100 million players.
So in the end, they had
a very simplified scope,
which made it feel
like it was going
to be possible to build this,
even with a limited runway
and a small team.
So the Doodle team was going
to be responsible for the game
client and the game servers
for hosting the multiplayer
sessions, and Cloud--
myself, in this case--
took on a task to build
a prototype matchmaker,
and make sure that that would,
in general, work, and then
eventually help them build a
production matchmaker on top
of Open Match.
So the initial
design, we started
with very basic practices.
We wanted to start with what
worked for other companies.
We knew that the
scale for a Doodle
could be unbelievably huge,
even by the standards of--
I've previously worked at
some pretty big game companies
on very successful AAA titles.
Even compared to those, we
knew that the number of people
who show up to the Google
search landing page every day
is well beyond that.
So we had to keep
thoughts about how
to scale this kind of at
the front of our minds.
So our first suggestion was to
get everything on Kubernetes
from the very beginning.
We really liked,
as Jonathan said
before, the fact that once
you're using Kubernetes
in your development
process, then you're already
in a really good place
where development looks
a lot like what you're
going to put on production,
and that can really help
accelerate your development.
So putting everything in Docker
containers from the very get-go
was a big
recommendation of ours.
And then make the
only platform service
for this game, which is the
matchmaker, as stateless
as possible so that you can
scale up and down the API just
to handle however
many players show up.
So to talk about
matchmaking, we really
wanted to help them
with the design,
so there were some
decision points.
These were things
that we had to come up
with a good answer for
because it's really
going to affect the complexity
of your matchmaking code.
So how is the Doodle
going to handle
if players don't show up?
Does the dual support
backfilling games?
If a player leaves
mid-game, do you
go find another
player to put in?
Can players join in
progress if there's
free slots on the server?
Are there multiple
queues for people
to queue in, to play with
different kinds of people?
Are there different regions that
you can queue for so that you
only play with people locally?
So in pretty much every
decision in this slide,
the Doodle team went
for making something
as simple as possible,
which turned out
to really pay dividends because
the whole process went pretty
smoothly, as Brian is
going to describe later.
Doodle's considerations
being horizontal scalability
really did inform the
decisions to try and keep
more complex scenarios, like
allowing people to join games
in progress, off the table.
The one thing that
they did want in there
was the ability to have
public versus private games.
So you would be able to get an
invitation that you could send
to your friends to have them
join directly your game,
but we just ended up making
those into two completely
separate pools of players.
Failover domains was a
thing that we were concerned
about-- like, what
happens if, heaven forbid,
there's an internet
issue or something
is unreachable for a certain
part of the player population?
Well, it turns out they
were able to solve that
just by putting everything
behind a Global Load Balancer,
and Brian will speak to that
some more in another slide.
So quickly, let me go
through a breakdown of how
a single matchmaking instance
worked for the Doodle
from left to right.
So there's a client-facing
API that the game clients
talk to directly.
That takes information
about that player
and writes it to
a Redis instance.
Then the matchmaking logic comes
along and reads from Redis.
Once it finds enough
players to make a match,
it persists that match
to a Cloud Pub/Sub topic,
which is actually
persistent data storage
layer, at this point.
So once you have put a
message into Cloud Pub/Sub,
it is guaranteed
to be delivered.
So there's no easy
way to lose it
once you've already done
the work of matching players
together.
So there's a server-facing
API that the game servers
connect to.
Once the game server connects,
it asks the server-facing API
to go and fetch a new match
from the Pub/Sub topic
and return it to
the game server.
And at that point, the
players get a message
out the client-facing
API, all the way
on the left, that
tells them the IP
and how to connect over a
WebSocket to the game server
directly.
That is not pictured
on this slide,
but there is a return
path for getting it back.
For anyone here who has
actually looked at Open Match,
you may notice that there's some
differences in the way things
are named here.
So Doodle was using Open
Match before Open Match
was even announced.
So by the time we worked
closely with Unity
to get it out the door--
the 0.1 version--
we tried to come up
with slightly more generic
names for the API that
did a better job of
describing scenarios
that were not Doodle-specific.
So now I'm going to
turn it over to Brian.
He's going to talk about
productionizing the Doodle.
BRIAN MURRAY: All right.
Thanks, Joe.
So I'm Brian Murray.
I'm a software engineer
on the Doodle team,
and I was the lead backend
engineer for the Halloween
Doodle.
So first, some unique challenges
we had to face along the way.
With Doodles, we
don't have the luxury
of a soft launch, where we
can gradually increase traffic
over time.
We basically have to
go from zero traffic
to all of Google's search
instantaneously, which
turns out to be difficult.
And since we run
Doodles on Google.com,
any downtime would
be really bad.
It could put the
project in jeopardy
because we can't exactly just
move Halloween back a couple
of days.
But luckily, we only had to keep
this thing alive for 48 hours.
So unlike most
game developers who
have to support a project
for months or years,
we only had to stay
awake for two days.
So I'll just briefly run through
our back end infrastructure.
You may remember a similar
diagram from earlier.
This is what we started with.
Then we met Joe.
He built us a matchmaker.
And this is essentially what
the inside of our clusters
looked like at launch.
When we needed to
scale up capacity,
we picked regions around the
globe to start clusters in.
We connected them to Cloud's
Global Load Balancer,
and then we just let it balance
the traffic geographically.
We didn't have any custom
logic for routing people
to different regions.
And when we needed
to scale it further,
we just added more clusters.
So here, we have a list of all
of the tools and technology
that we used to
develop the backends.
As you can see here,
everything that we used
is available externally.
There's no Google-specific
internal magic
behind the scenes, and even the
way we interacted with Cloud
was very similar to how
an external customer would
have interacted with them.
So I'll go a little bit into
our development process,
for those that are interested.
We separated our development
into two GCP projects, one
for production, one
for development.
And we kept all of
the resources separate
between these
projects, which ensured
that anything we were
doing in development
wouldn't suddenly
break production.
And within our
development project,
we had our own clusters
for development.
So I had a cluster.
Jonathan had a cluster.
We had a cluster
for load testing.
And it was really important that
we had no special configuration
for these.
They were basically
production clusters,
but we wanted to make sure
that behavior in these clusters
was as close to
prod as possible.
And finally, we wanted
to make the process
of creating and destroying
them really easy.
Because when you end
up in a weird state
after hours of debugging,
the last thing you want to do
is to have to figure out, how
do I fix this in real-time?
It's nice to be able to just
throw everything away and start
from scratch.
So we wrote a couple of scripts
to make this process easy.
OK.
So we have a game.
We have a plan for
how to scale things.
How do we actually figure
out how many servers we need?
So in our case, we
knew roughly how much
traffic to expect by looking at
numbers from previous Doodles.
We knew how long our games were.
And if we combined these two,
we could use some basic math
to estimate how
many people would
be connected at a given time.
So we did that.
We extrapolated a little
bit, and we came up
with an initial estimate.
We knew our numbers
wouldn't be perfect,
but we just hoped that they
would be close enough just
to get a rough idea of how
much traffic to expect.
OK.
So now we have our
initial estimate.
We need to figure out
if we can actually
handle that much traffic.
So we wrote a custom client--
a headless client-- to
simulate the process
of connecting to the
matchmaker, joining into a game,
playing through it,
and then disconnecting.
And then when we wanted
to run load tests,
we just started a bunch of
these in a Kubernetes job,
pointed it at our
load test cluster,
and then let them run wild.
And our strategy throughout
this whole process
was to start really
small, only scale up
when we were confident that
the system could handle
a given amount of traffic.
So here, we have
a quick example.
We have 10 clients per second
pointed at a cluster here.
When we're confident that it
can handle that much traffic,
we scale that up to 20.
Looks good at 20,
so we got a 30.
And then in this
example, we noticed
that, at 30 clients per
second, our matchmaker
starts having issues.
So let's say our CPU
usage is spiking.
We investigate.
We decide that we just need more
matchmakers, so we add more.
We rerun our tests.
We make sure that it's stable
and, if everything looks good,
we carry on.
And then, occasionally,
we would run longer tests
because there are certain things
that you can only figure out
after maybe 10 or
12 hours of load,
that you wouldn't be able
to see in an hour test.
So we would run tests
for 12 hours or 24 hours
to verify that these
issues weren't happening.
And finally, since our estimates
initially were pretty rough,
we wanted to make sure
that we ran load tests well
above our peak traffic numbers--
our expected peak
traffic numbers.
And so in our case, we
scaled up our load tests
to double what we
expected at peak traffic,
and that basically gave us
an idea of what would happen
if the Doodle went viral.
OK.
So we're ready for production.
At this point, we set up
monitoring and alerting
so that we can have
some visibility into how
the launch is going.
We switched from running Redis
internally in our clusters
to using Cloud Memorystore,
and that provided us
better guarantees
of reliability.
It gave us people we could
talk to if issues came up.
And then we also worked with
Cloud professional services
to come up with a launch plan.
They helped us with stuff
like capacity planning,
reserving resources, setting
up on-call rotations,
that kind of stuff.
OK.
Launch time.
Time to turn everything
on and hope for the best.
So we wanted to spin up
our clusters far enough
ahead of time to ensure
that they were stable
before the Doodle
actually went live.
On the other hand,
we didn't want
to give too much lead
time because running
36,000 CPUs doing nothing
is kind of expensive.
Since we were only
running for two days,
we gave ourselves about three
hours to wrap everything up.
I would have liked to
have maybe four or five,
but it was almost enough.
From there, we just kept a
close eye on Stackdriver.
And if any metrics came up
that we hadn't planned on,
Stackdriver allowed us
to create dashboards
for those in real-time,
which was really nice.
We worked with Cloud
professional services
to fix any issues as they arose.
And as I mentioned earlier,
we scaled our load tests up
to double our
expected peak traffic,
while our average load ended
up being about double what
we expected.
So it was really valuable to
have seen how the system dealt
with this amount of
traffic beforehand,
as opposed to having
to deal with that
for the first time
on launch day.
We had to add a couple more
clusters to compensate.
Luckily, though, the process
for spinning those up only
took about 15 minutes.
And so it ended up not
being that big of a deal,
and we were able to do
that without any downtime.
And other than that, the
launch went pretty smoothly.
So just a quick summary
to wrap things up.
Our backend and frontend
engineers worked very closely
together, and that
fact was very valuable
because the close communication
helped us avoid a lot of design
churn, and it kept our
final design simple.
I know this is a Cloud-sponsored
talk, but as a team that
doesn't normally think
about Cloud at all
or work with Cloud at all, we
found it a really solid base
for this type of project.
We never had to manage
any VMs, migrate services,
deal with downtime.
And the cloud documentation made
Kubernetes surprisingly easy
to learn.
Speaking of
Kubernetes, Kubernetes
made our scaling
process a lot simpler,
which was really
useful on launch day.
Once we had our
clusters configured,
it was easy to just
start more of them
to handle the
unexpected load, and we
could do that without downtime.
And lastly, just a
shout out to Nita Meng,
who is our contact from
Cloud professional services.
She did a lot of
work to help make
sure this launch went
smoothly, and she
was a huge part of its success.
And if you're interested
in learning more,
Google Cloud wrote
up a blog post
about the project, which
you can find if you
Google Halloween Doodle GCP.
And if you want
to play the game,
you can go to
Google.com/doodles,
and it'll be in
our Archive page.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]